hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today is my friend Doug Evans Doug
was the co-founder of organic Avenue
which was one of the original og juice
bars in New York City he was also the
founder of the infamous juice arrow
which we talk about today and he's the
author of a new book called the sprout
book so today we're gonna talk about
healthy eating nutrition sprouting why
you should get into it how to do it why
it's beneficial how to boost your immune
system during this interesting moment of
sequestration we talked about his
perspective on the juice arrow
experience and lots of other great stuff
so I think you guys are gonna enjoy it I
love this man and without further ado
this is me and Doug Evans enjoy so good
to see you always pleasure spend time
with you my friend we had planned on
doing this podcast I think maybe the end
of February when did the book come out
book came out April 7th but we can't we
were going to get together it was it was
in the very beginning of the quarantine
era right and we decided we should push
it so here we are
you're the first person that said to me
I'm gonna honor the social distancing
I'm gonna go home and I'm not gonna have
any guess yeah
and this is the first you're the first
in-person interview other than on
podcast with Julie since February we
brought in a nurse to check temperature
and to administer an antibody tests that
we're both according to this test
coronavirus free so we can be together
although we have a long table so I think
we're still maintaining some level of
social distance but I got to tell you
it's really nice to be able to just do a
podcast with somebody sitting across
from me as opposed to on a computer
screen yeah I feel like it's so
different to be in person
yeah like I'll I'll travel anywhere to
be with someone in person I know and you
drove here from your
compound which we're gonna get into in a
minute but I think before we launch into
all the fascinating things that we're
going to talk about today it's important
to just acknowledge this very strange
moment that we're in right now today is
Tuesday June 2nd there are cities on
fire right now protesting you know now
across the globe protests across the
globe there's a lot of social unrest at
the moment and there is sort of an
awkwardness of having a conversation
about anything but that right now which
we are going to do we're going to talk
about other things that are that I think
are also as you'll find out you know
tangentially related to at least
coronavirus immunity things like that
but I just wanted to you know
acknowledge that we're in a very strange
moment right now and it's also difficult
to figure out how to appropriately
communicate around that yeah I I have to
say yesterday was the first protest I
went to since I was 13 years old
mmm and like I was on the phone with our
mutual friend Mike and like what what
can we do and like I thought about like
I need to show up so again another multi
hour drive to Palm Desert and the
strange thing like in the car going
there I'm thinking like well this who
knows what could happen there right just
who knows yeah so it was just something
that like the world is dealing with
that's just been around you know from
like long before and I'm far from
historian but it's just like I don't cry
often but I look and I'm just feeling
feelings that just like no longer can
just sit on the sidelines yeah there's a
heaviness to all of it I found myself
despairing and also feeling a little
paralyzed as to what to do and how to
respond to what's happening and also
knowing like this is you know on some
level like this has to happen in order
for us to grow and mature and evolve and
you know raise the the level of
conscious awareness on the planet and
it's not that I condone violence but to
provide space for those important voices
to be heard is super important and it's
long overdue and we're seeing a lot of
people right now who are who are and
have been for generations
disenfranchised and muffled and this is
a tipping point right now and I think
what America will become is going to be
defined by what transpires in the very
short term yeah this this is part of
history and it's a time like we've never
experienced before
what was the protest like there was
probably you know couple thousand people
mm-hmm it was you know relatively
peaceful but kind of mixed a lot of
mixed race and you know a lot of loud
chanting and it felt really
uncomfortable for me you know to say you
know hand you know hands up don't shoot
like because that was something like I
never you know had to think about before
or to experience on a physical level
mm-hm
you know as part of a protest so some
people had some words you know there
were some signs and but relatively
protests in Palm Desert so it was you
know there for and there was curfew and
there was a lot of police there was a
lot of military there were like tanks
and Humvees and other things you know
just in the area and the helicopters so
it was very like very tense
yeah time and it's it's evolving and
changing so rapidly you know by the time
this goes up in a week things could look
very different and I think there's a
sense of just you know precarious
uncertainty about the whole thing and
and and an awareness and an
acknowledgement that literally anything
could happen right now yeah I mean the
one thing that I like took away is that
there's nothing funny about this like
there is no joke that can be uttered
whatsoever under any circumstances right
100% nod and the I was hearing like
parts of jokes or other things like uh
and not being malicious but like one
woman you know had her mask on and she
saw a sign that said you know I can't
breathe and you know she's like I can't
breathe in this mask and and like I'm
cringing because like like her level of
uncomfortability was disconnected with
the the fact that oh you know life and
life's were lost
yeah and so it's just there's a
seriousness in a darkness you know that
will invariably you know turn into light
like I think it has to turn into light
you're optimistic I uh I have to be I
mean you're a very energetic optimistic
guy by Nature yeah but if anything was
gonna temper that it would I would
suspect it would be this yeah I I mean I
wasn't tempered by the the kovat right I
mean I took it seriously I honored it
because people were you know
legitimately scared
but I I wasn't but this is a whole
different level of like his you know
from generations of oppression and
unfairness that caused me to really
recognize like you know white fragility
white privilege and in ways that I had
never thought about before yeah
one of the big lessons that I'm taking
from this as you know look a privileged
white male is that it's not really for
people like us to say that much it's
more important that we listen and allow
ourselves to be open and to be educated
right I quickly cuz I don't I don't know
what to say but I think the things are
that there are people that are
privileged that are focusing on giving
them more superficial material
inconsequential things and there's
people that like you that may have
privilege but that you are of service
and that your voice is very powerful and
the impact that you're having in the
world is very powerful and it is it is
difficult to figure out where and how to
direct that right now though yeah I
don't know I mean I look at like my
purpose and after like everything that
I've been through and you know
ironically two months ago I did a
podcast with Marianne Williamson and the
topic of the podcast was food you know
food poverty food equality food deserts
because so many of the underprivileged
underserved are malnourished and their
options for nutrition you know our fast
food mm-hmm and processed food and
refined sugar and those things are you
know the planting of the the toxic seed
that can affect their health moving
forward so that independent of what's
going on with the other kind of main
topic that's a very big topic that just
needs to be addressed and I think you're
addressing that in many different ways
you know with your work and that's what
I feel compelled to do with mine yeah I
mean that was a big reason why I wanted
to get you back in here not just cell
right the fact that you wrote this
amazing book that we're gonna talk about
but the manner in which this book speaks
to the underlying cause of so much ill
in America and across the world which is
the fact that the people who need access
to improve better nutrition more than
anybody are the people that are most
deprived of it and there's a sense in
the kind of you know quote unquote
wellness community or even the V the
vegan community that this is a
privileged lifestyle it involves going
to erawan or Whole Foods and super foods
that are very expensive to buy and
recipes that are difficult to prepare
and time-consuming and simply out of
reach for the average middle-class
person let alone the person who's living
in a food desert or in an inner city or
on food stamps or just basically trying
to you know get through the day with two
jobs and put a little bit of food on the
table for their kids and right in front
of us is this beautiful solution that's
been here all along and I will admit and
we talked about this when we did an
Instagram live not too long ago that
despite the fact that I'm steeped in
this community and in this movement that
I myself knew very little about how to
actually produce sprouts and what they
could do for my health and how simple
and cost-effective it is so why don't we
get into that a little bit yeah I mean
it's interesting what would drove me to
like eating and living a healthy
lifestyle is my mother died of cancer my
aunt got diabetes and they chopped off
her feet below her ankles and my uncle
got heart disease and died then my
father got heart disease died in the
same hospital as my mother and my
brother has had three strokes and a
heart attack and his obese so and and
that's the beginning and I'll just I'll
just stop it there
that I thought that I was genetically
cursed I never heard of microbiome I've
never
heard of vegan I just thought like oh
you know I'm genetically cursed and I
was 36 pounds overweight and in a two
week period I went from eating anything
to vegetarian vegan than raw vegan how
long ago was that 21 years ago 1999
April and so that I was living in in
dual world part of my world was working
making money and then the other part was
how can I eat the healthiest food what
can I learn what books can I read what
seminars can I go - what speakers can I
hear and that you know was my first
exposure to sprouts
like I never thought about before I was
like what are these little things and I
had some alfalfa sprout and I had some
mung bean sprouts and then I started to
juice wheatgrass and that was 21 years
ago and in the back of my mind I was
always thought like oh if I'm ever
hungry if I'm ever homeless like I can
just grow sprouts so like that was just
in the back of my mind and then you know
fast-forward through two years ago after
you know my world my privileged world
had the apocalypse I moved to the desert
because I wanted to be away from
everybody and everything and I want to
be in nature and I want to like watch
the Sun Rise watch the sunset and
connect with stars and not have noise
pollution light pollution kind of smoke
pollution break dust and all those
things so I moved to the desert and I
might as well have been homeless because
I was living in a tent and I was an hour
and 15 minutes away from Whole Foods so
this was a food desert quite literally
really was a food desert and so I went
back to that thought that was planted
that seed that was planted in my head 21
years ago
about sprouting and within a month I was
sprouting a dozen different seeds and
about 50% of my calories were from
sprouts and just I did the math and I
had eaten about $12 worth of seeds and
that was like this aha moment and said
wow like why isn't everyone sprouting
and I got criticized in my last world
because a cold-pressed juice was $7
mm-hmm and same price if you bought went
to a juice bar or air one you'd spend $7
for a juice but if you made it home it
was still $7 but if you two go buy one
ounce of broccoli sprouts in the
farmer's market or three ounces in the
health food store you're gonna spend $5
and I had now first-hand experience that
that was about 30 cents worth of seeds
and I was like wow people may not be
able to afford $5 but they can afford 30
cents yeah my experience with sprouts
and this is also something that came up
when we did our Instagram live my
experience is going to the fancy grocery
store and buying those those plastic
containers of sprouts where they're you
know it's literally could fit in the
fist of your hand and it's freaking
expensive and you have to eat them
pretty quickly or they go rancid yeah
and so the appearance is that this is a
very costly endeavor this is a this is a
luxury to be able to eat these things
what I didn't realize is how simple it
is to make these things at home and how
incredibly nutritious they are for so
many reasons I think my first kind of
aha moment was watching a video that
that dr. Michael Greger did a while back
about broccoli sprouts and how amazingly
like they're that they're like this is
the king of the sprouts so I started
building those into my routine but I
never never occurred to me to try to
make them at home like I would just go
to erawan or Whole Foods and buy them
but I always felt weird because they are
so expensive and I never wanted to buy
too much
well I mean that's the the the amazing
thing is two tablespoons of broccoli
sprout seeds will yield a minimum of six
cups of broccoli sprouts so just like do
that math it's like exponential growth
in like five to seven days so if you're
thinking one cup of broccoli sprouts has
about 60 percent of the recommended
daily allowance of vitamin C and it has
soluble and insoluble fiber and it's
green so it has the antioxidant
chlorophyll and no rocket science
required like you can take a glass jar
add the two tablespoons of seeds add
water and then just rinse them twice a
day and you will have your bounty of
broccoli sprouts in under a week right
it is it is that simple which is amazing
because I always thought well yeah you
rent you soak them and you rinse them
but this is gonna be like a whole thing
I'm like I'm just not interested but
then I saw you do it and now you know
this some interesting people I've
cottoned onto your book and they're
sharing you've been posting it this guy
what's his name John Cole like the juji
mu food guy yeah like millions of
followers on Instagram is like he's like
a body I don't know who this guy is but
he's like he was that America's Got
Talent
it was that really he's like a super
Jack and he's flexible he did a chair
split uh-huh while holding like like
someone over his head so he's flexible
acrobatic is that what he did on
America's Cup yeah it's like I've never
heard of this guy he's got like 1.6
million people on Instagram but now he's
making sprouting videos like shouting
out your book he's like a very unlikely
ambassador I mean he's super healthy of
course but but but it's been cool at all
I kind of watch all these people take
what they're learning from your book and
then sharing it and seeing some of this
stuff like go viral well the thing is
that at one point if you had vegetable
in your life and maybe it's too I'm not
a historian and I cheated my way through
high school so I really don't know when
but there was a point in time that if
you had vegetables you either grew them
yourself or you knew who grew them and
fast forward today most people have no
idea where their vegetables are coming
from they're getting them in the
supermarket and most of America is in
food deserts so they don't even have the
quality of vegetables and and produce in
their supermarket so now we live in a
convenience culture so when I was living
in New York San Francisco LA there was
always access to fresh produce either in
a farmers market or a health food store
or supermarket could always get fresh
produce but when I went back to nature
and in my community there's 600 people
in a hundred square miles and there is
no health food store where we live this
power of empowerment and sovereignty
around sprouting was was something that
I couldn't believe it
like when I came up with this like idea
I thought that it was flawed like there
I must be missing something and that
kind of led to me you know calling up a
Michael dr. Michael Greger and calling
up dr. oz and calling up Mark Hyman and
Dean Ornish and joel fuhrman and joel
khan calling these people and saying hey
talk to me about sprouts and you know I
even talked to dr. Josh axe you know who
wrote the Kido book so some of these
people were Kido some where paleo
somewhere functional medicine some were
plant-based and the thing that they all
had in common they all love sprouts
mm-hmm and they all had good things to
say about sprouts and that was after
those that part of my research was done
I even spoke to Andy while right who is
hard to get ahold of
and he loves broccoli sprouts and it was
just like wow nobody should talk in my
sprouts and there was nothing and I
couldn't believe and Juji mu fou like
adds sprouts to every meal like he's
growing more sprouts and he can eat
which is a big feat because he eats 4000
calories a day but he adds sprouts every
meal and like I envisioned I think you
talked about manifestation like I
manifested like in my mind like there
would be a guy who you never in a
million years would eat sprouts like
this was a guy who you'd expect to eat a
cow alive and um like now the guy is
like eating spouse every I've died super
sprout guy I think that that sprouts
sprouting is in dire need of like hiring
a new publicist because in my mind you
know at my age when I think of sprouts
and sprouting I think of the you know
wiry haired you know old woman who might
have a penchant for the Grateful Dead
like wandering around the health food
store and her Birkenstocks talking about
sprouts and it's not that it's like it's
not that appealing it sounds like oh
this is a hippie thing this is not gonna
be tasty and it's certainly not going to
sate my appetite like as an athlete and
you're somebody who you've helped
educate me because you're just eating
this stuff like all the time and telling
me that you're getting full so I've been
experimenting with this because I didn't
believe you but it's actually true like
you're getting you can get quite a few
calories but more importantly the
nutrient density of what you're eating
is so profound that I found that it it
tampers my appetite when I'm eating
these things because my body is actually
getting so many nutrients that there's
some signal that gets switched where
it's like you're good well here's the
thing I don't think it's possible to
overeat sprouts like you just add some
like if you gave me
even today like if you gave me like
fresh-cut like French you know potato
wedges that were deep-fried with salt
like there's part of my brain that says
you know I won't touch them if I have
one bite I'll end up like eating over
game over I'll eat everyone on the
tables but with sprouts like you know
when you're done like you're just done
you'll eat as many sprouts as you can
eat and then you're done
but the insight that I had was people
just looked at sprouts as a garnish you
know maybe have some mung bean sprouts
and some miso soup or have some alfalfa
sprouts on a sandwich and that's when I
went to you know this Michelin star chef
in New York John George and I said do
you sprouts
I love sprouts I said can you give me a
recipe that uses sprouts and then I
found a recipe developer who did Laila
Ali's book mm-hmm and she did Oprah's
recipe book and I said here's a
challenge I'm doing a book I need 40
recipes that are all raw 100%
plant-based that are 50% made out of
sprouts so it's all order and she said
are you serious and I said I'm serious
as a heart attack
we will you do this so I literally took
the entire advance from the publisher
and paid her to do these recipes and to
like edit the the bought the book uh-huh
walk me through the process of sprouting
like educate me about how how you do
this like where do you get the seeds
what exactly do you do is this really as
easy as you say it is like talk to me
about so I'm gonna grab a prop this is
like Show and Tell Doug brought like all
kinds of jars of stuff
and these we should say for people are
watching on YouTube in the mid in the
middle of the table here you brought
this this is not a prop
yeah those this those are sunflower
sprouts and how long did it take for
those to grow one week Wow
and and this so this is how they're like
and these are sunflower and these are
for people that are just listening on
audio there they're dark they're black
essentially so they look very different
from the sunflower seeds that you would
get at the convenience store that are
covered in salt yeah that was another
insight that I had is that there's a lot
of varieties like people think of when I
grew up there was Red Delicious apples
and Golden Delicious and maybe a
Macintosh and now we know there's
hundreds of varieties of apples right
there's probably a hundred varieties of
sunflowers and that's just a black oil
organic sunflower seed you know it's
different than anything I've ever seen
before and when you think of sprouts I
mean most people just think of alfalfa
sprouts yeah there's so many there's so
many sprouts and the reason why I wrote
the book is really for myself because I
was confused as to how do you handle two
things that look identical but have an
entirely different sprouting protocol
uh-huh
like the you know I'll walk through the
sunflower sprout process so you take
those sunflower seeds and you immerse
them into water and you let them soak
for eight hours or twelve hours
overnight so you just put them in a jar
like one of those in front of you right
that's right and then you let them sit
you can put them under the counter just
not in direct sunlight and then 12 hours
later you rinse out the water and then
you add some fresh water and then
you strain them and you let them sit
like this at a 45 degree angle and these
are literally two days old and you can
see how those same seeds are just
starting to germinate right so you see
the germination here and you've got a
lid on here with it with a wire mesh so
it allows it to breathe and you
essentially put it on a rack that kind
of tips it with the wire mesh down so
any any moisture just you know
evaporates out that yeah grab gravity
will cause it to strain and that's just
2 days 2 days and if you didn't have the
this special wire mesh screen you could
just use cheesecloth organic cheesecloth
and a rubber band and so these tools
were just so simple and so you soak them
and then once they start to generate the
tail and they germinate then you can lay
them out and the the modalities for
sprouting the methods of sprouting you
can use a jar you can use a bag you can
use soil or you can use an unbleached
paper towel or they make these sprouting
mediums that are like coconut husk or
Jude and it's almost like the seed wants
to sprout in any environment like like
it's definite purpose in life is to
sprout and so these seeds that look just
like a little pebble or something our
complete living organism in a dormant
state and with a little like in nature
they go into the ground and it rains and
smooster and then they sprout in our
environment they will sit dormant until
you decide oh I want to be able to eat
these and then you can sprout them and
you know you're like I know I've heard
you say you know about protein and you
don't use protein powder use protein
powders I mean very sparingly so this is
a green pea
you could take a look at these these are
this is a mix of mung beans green peas
garbanzo beans and it's a it's a protein
blend and those lentils in here two or
three one lentils or these are the green
peas does is a green Peter I don't have
lentils in this in this batch but these
you can soak them and strain them and in
three days they're edible uh-huh it's
just like that and one cup of those is
seven grams of protein and has soluble
and insoluble fiber it's crunchy and it
will almost adapt to any flavor of any
sauce you put lemon on it you put soil
salt on it you put an oil on it you put
a marinara sauce on whatever you put on
it this just becomes the texture that
you're eating or you can just take
handfuls of it and eat it the way that
you do right yeah that's basically your
your program yeah III do that but what
what the reason why I did the recipes is
because like I'm not like normal mm-hmm
well you know like thethe I know it's
only true definitely not so I know that
for me I am definitely eating to live
like I'm eating to live and I realize as
joel fuhrman wrote and many others most
people are like living to eat like when
can i eat next what do i eat next and
they're you know food pornography and
other things to me i've gotten to the
point that I realized that food is a
necessity I realize that I can be prone
to tripping on addiction you know which
is why I eliminated and it's salt added
sugar added oil because I will eat when
I'm not hungry
and I will overeat and that's where like
the insight of eating the sprouts like
raw sprouts there's no compulsion
whatsoever to overeat to sprout like I'm
these I'm not getting off on eating the
sprout
it's like I'm eating them I'm enjoying
them and then I'm done and I'll go on to
the next thing right how do you know
when they're done so you said three days
I mean part of in the in the book you
know that every seed has its journey and
like you can take these are really
pretty he's getting more stuff out these
are these chia seeds or chia so the chia
seeds will literally grow 20 times the
size and so if you think about like
getting your omega-3s you could get them
from chia seed if you soak the chia
seeds and you put them literally like on
chia pet or on an unglazed unglazed clay
pot or saucer in about a week they will
grow 20 times their size they'll
increase we're right now they're really
concentrated hard almost like the size
of a poppy seed they will grow soluble
and insoluble fiber the omega-3s and
you'll have chlorophyll and it'll be
like a little leafy green accent and you
can eat the whole thing the root the
stem the leaf everything is edible so
why is the the germinated sprouted
version of the seed more nutritious than
just eating the seed itself like I could
put this these chia seeds in my smoothie
or any of these you know sesame seeds
whatever kind of seed on my salad etc
but there's something about when they're
in that germinated state that suddenly
makes they become more and more
nutritionally dense and also those
nutrients become more bioavailable yeah
it there I'm gonna do my best to unpack
this with the caveat not a scientist not
a nutritionist not a doctor but you're
the sprout book author guy yeah so
that's all I'm going to do my best
so the
seed itself like if we talk about
broccoli seeds and I have some broccoli
seeds here so the broccoli seeds you
know I don't know that I've ever seen
broccoli seeds before so the broccoli
seed has the plant intelligence and the
programming in that seed that if it's in
the right environment which is moisture
and darkness it will germinate the
amount of glue carafe Ihnen which is the
precursor to sulfur faint in that seed
is what that is there will be no more
mm-hmm
but as that seed sprouts it will
increase the fiber content it will
increase the vitamin C content it will
increase the protein because it's able
to transmute and transform the elements
of water and air and light into an
entirely you know more developed
structure and every sprout is the
manifestation of the seed will grow
without fertilizer without other things
up until a certain point and then after
that point it's done like either you eat
it or you plant it in soil or or add
some sort of fertilizers to it because
it will expend its life mm-hmm so the
reason why broccoli seeds have fifty to
a hundred times the amount of the
precursor to Sofer fame is because as
the broccoli gets bigger you're not
getting any more sulfur faint you're
just right you're getting more broccoli
but you're not getting more of this so
far faint so in the efficient stage the
fledgling stage of the seed so you
actually if you were just looking for
sulfur fain you could grind those
broccoli seeds up chew them
grind them because you want to grind
them chew em to mix the glue carafe
Ihnen with the myrosinase the the enzyme
that activates them so they're almost
imagine they're in like separate little
pockets inside and when you mix them
together that's when the mechanism
activates it in the sulfur faint
compound is created with like it's a
science project all happening in nature
to protect the seed and to protect the
plant
I keep hearing about sulforaphane all of
a sudden like I hadn't really heard much
about that and I just did a podcast with
dr. wolf bolsa wits and he just goes on
and on about sulforaphane so why is that
such an important nutrient I I think and
it's it's interesting I just read a dr.
B dr. Biber fueled you know I just read
the book phenomenal and I also just
interviewed dr. Jed Fahey who was the
professor at Johns Hopkins University
who 20-plus years ago went on a search
and to find which vegetable or which
broccoli had the most sulforaphane and
so so fer fame or the precursor
glucoraphanin exists in all cruciferous
vegetables so kale bok choy cauliflower
broccoli even wasabi it fits into this
cruciferous vegetable family so the the
mechanism of sulfur fame was just proven
to be able to cause a biological
reaction in the body that you know they
call it anti-cancer it's not a cancer
cure but in the case of ASD autism
spectrum the spectrum disorder in in
that case the sulfur feign kind of
creates the heat shock proteins so it's
simulating what's happening you know
with the heat and causing the body to
shift so
all of the research the why people are
over the moon with this is there's
probably 1500 research papers produced
in the last 12 months on the powerful
potent factors so there's money behind
so far fame there's money behind the
testing they're doing all sorts of
testing and getting very positive
results that although there's there's no
cure for autism the most effective
treatment and this is like National
Institute of Health peer-reviewed papers
are the benefits of treating with sulfur
fain and so they're trying to figure out
like sulfur fain supplements very
expensive like $60 for a bottle with 30
capsules and the efficacy of that is
super low right that's something I
talked about with dr. B as well well the
I don't even know about the efficacy
versus the financial inaccessibility
versus just buying the the broccoli
seeds soaking them and getting your own
sprouts and so the Cancer Research is
the the mechanism that prevents the
survival mechanism for the plant somehow
in nature this was designed to ward off
pests and so that reaction ends up
having the positive effect on the cell
on a cellular level and within the
stomach and you've you've had more
experts on the microbiome and the gut so
imagine you're feeding your yourself
this fresh raw living super concentrated
nutritious fiber rich a plant that has
compounds and molecules that have now
been tested right it's not subjective
anymore there's been enough testing to
talk about the impact of these on this
whole slew
of very serious health issues but the
kicker to bring it back to sprouts yeah
and not to bury the lede here is that if
you look at the kingdom of cruciferous
vegetables and the foods that are rife
in in sulfuric Ain like broccoli is if
I'm not mistaken if not at the top close
to the top yeah
but the comparison between broccoli and
broccoli sprouts is like a non-starter
right like the sprouts have something
like 10 times the amount see oh yeah and
for pennies you can be eating this stuff
I mean it's such a no-brainer I mean
literally there's you can get the
calories let's just talk about lentils
for a second
I'm just shifting from broccoli and so
far feign to Len tools if you were to
take a cup of lentils and sprout them
you get two cups of lentils right
because they're growing right they're
absorbing the water they're increasing
the fiber they're growing a tail they're
growing volume if you were to compare
one cup of sprouted lentils versus one
cup of cooked lentils and I'm all for it
lentils of all sine so I'm not judging
I'm just stating the facts when you
sprout the lentils you double the
antioxidant levels hmm you triple the
vitamin C so like why wouldn't you just
take water and then you could still
season them anyway you want but you're
getting this food that has a lifeforce
right that you know modern science isn't
measuring you know ways and the
significance but you can feel like I had
a an interview with Joe de Sena from
Spartan uh-huh yeah I know Joe so Joe
you know was like living under a rock
like did was not sprouting and now on
his compound wherever he is in
Pennsylvania
like he's sprouting sprout mean he's
about a sending me picture
you know I registered the domain
sproutin after sparta oh you did that's
funny yeah cause like he just was so
kind of into like the sprout yeah he's a
closet hippie to that guy when you get
him talking I think he grew up if I'm
not mistaken I think he had a vegetarian
mom and grew up in a farm right and he's
been you know he eats I don't know if he
would call himself plant-based or vegan
but his diet is much more plant-based
and I think people in the kind of
Spartan Race community might might
understand but one of the things that I
love about this whole sprouting
conversation is that it's not contingent
upon any kind of diet dogma like you
said earlier like whether you're paleo
keto loco loco whatever it's like this
is just being healthy no matter where
you're at like this is a good idea to
build into your routine
well I being plant-based and being
passionate about plant-based I would
invariably you know be people would just
assume that I was like a violent vegan
right and confrontational and it just
got boring you know answering the
questions where do you get your protein
from and this and I like this and I just
decided not to go there like I wanted
sprouts to be for everybody if it's one
sprout your diet or 10% of your sprouts
your diet or like juji mu foo adding
sprouts to every meal like this was
something that was accessible and if we
think about in these underserved
communities where Dean Ornish in in the
book had mentioned that he was a
consultant to McDonald's and when they
put McDonald's they put salads on the
menu was $5.99 for a de minimis amount
of calories yeah right iceberg lettuce I
think just but who is gonna spend six
dollars for a salad when you could spend
ninety nine cent for a burger and get
more calories so the idea that for 99
cents you could actually have something
that was chewy
and meaningful and nutritious like
that's what we needed to do is to plant
these seeds so like the more sprouts you
eat this is another insight have
familiar are you with Weight Watchers I
have a passing familiarity at best so a
few years ago they shifted to a point
system mmm in Weight Watchers so a piece
of bread might be four points a Snickers
bar might be eight points sprouts zero
points on the system so if you're on
Weight Watchers you can eat as many
sprouts as you want they just encourage
it like well just add sprouts like you
want to over they don't say this and
I'll be careful not to say if you want
to over eat eat sprouts but I just said
it so but like literally spouts are a
lot of fiber some protein rich in rich
in vitamins and probably and you know we
have to be in full integrity until your
microbiome adjust to the spouts there
may be some some flagellation I've seen
us yeah I mean I you hear that a lot
when you're switching from one dietary
protocol to the next especially if
you're going from a lower fiber diet to
a higher fiber diet or you start eating
more beans or something like that that
you're gonna have that problem but you
have to allow that gut flora to
literally seed itself with these new
foods and there's an adjustment period
but if you can get through that you will
adjust and then your ability to kind of
digest these things will come in
lockstep and that a lot of that
flatulence will go away well also if you
were to mix sprouts with fermented food
like the you know you're not they're not
selling it yet but fermented broccoli
sprouts mm-hmm like you can sprout a lot
of things and you can ferment a lot of
things and you know how easy it is to
make sauerkraut right just water and
salt and cabbage mm-hmm so you could
start to think about
sprouting to also have like as opposed
to taking a probiotic supplement you
could do things in your diet to create
natural probiotics yeah or prebiotics
right yes essentially what this is you
know more and more we're hearing about
the microbiome and again I just did this
podcast with well bolsa whit's who's
just super bullish on sprouts and
essentially plant diversity and
increasing your fiber intake like you
people want it you mentioned earlier
people want to know where you get your
protein but the truth is none of us have
a problem meeting our protein
requirements but something like 97% of
people are fiber deficient we need to be
eating more fiber the science is
incontrovertible and when you look at
sprouts not only are they super high in
antioxidants their anti-inflammatory
they have these anti anti-cancer
properties and you could you know I'd
like to hear more about all these
nutritional benefits but also they're
incredibly good for your gut flora and
your microbiome and the more we learn
about how important that is and the
interrelationship between that your
microbiome and your well-being in
general or or you know how it's
contributing to disease it's becoming
more and more incumbent upon us to be
paying attention to these things and
trying to serve our microbiome in the
best way possible
yeah well look I think it's it's the
microbiome
it's the calories right it's the
convenience like what is more convenient
than being able to make food with water
and seeds in days and especially this
was a big topic you know during kovat
and I can say the combination of
sheltering in place and the book coming
out caused the leading sprout seed
companies to literally sell out and
their sales have doubled and tripled of
selling seeds yeah I mean a couple
observations on that first of all when
kovat hit my heart went out to you
because I can't imagine trying to birth
book into the world we're at a moment
when everybody's in quarantine but in
retrospect there was kind of a beautiful
confluence you know not to like be
dismissive of Cove it in any manner but
to the extent that people were at home
looking for things to do you saw a lot
about people making sourdough bread but
sprouting played perfectly into people
learning about how to take care of
themselves and I think an underserved
conversation in the whole pandemic
coronavirus narrative is a lack of
understanding about the control that we
have over our immune health and the
importance that we the importance of
taking care of our immune systems and
how to do it well I don't know if you
read the research you know coming out of
Wuhan you know of the the common thread
among the Cova deaths had a lot to do
with their fiber deficiency I didn't
hear that I mean I heard about vitamin D
deficiency and I've heard about all
kinds of you know cofactors whether it's
you know obesity diabetes heart disease
it's another cofactor was fiber mm-hmm
and fiber and got health so you know so
much of this has to do with the what
you're eating right and you know this um
from a level of people may not have been
able to go to crossroads right or to
plant food and wine or to air one but
the sprouting is a open door kind of
access point into plant-based that is so
accessible so low cost and you know it
brings back when we were running organic
Avenue in New York City we pretty much
lost money on almost every product that
we made mmm because we didn't add we had
no additives
no fillers no process everything was
just a hundred percent organic plants
with high labor high rent and high food
waste because you couldn't manage it but
when we had sprouts in a dish it was
actually profitable it was actually
profitable because we were growing them
you know on the countertop to be able to
do that right so I think from that level
of people like I encourage people in the
book and I have citations for everything
I independent of the publisher I hired
my own fact checker just to check all
the facts because I wanted it you know
if it wasn't accurate I don't want to
put that information out there and even
though the science is changing there was
a good stamp on there the the fact that
like the information about sprouts like
this looks to me the the sunflower
sprouts we're looking at look like green
vegetables to me what do I do you try
one rich just eat them like this
just eat them like that you're gonna
have to talk cuz I'm like yeah to talk
no no
so the fact that you can have something
like literally grow your own food right
and an activity some of the like I'm not
doing any kind of consulting but I'm
doing a lot of evangelical work around
sprouting and the families like the kids
are excited to like watch the sprouts
grow mm-hmm
and they don't understand like what's
happening like how does it go from this
small to this to this and like
everything changes it's like it's a
dynamic game where the nutrition as you
were describing kind of varies over this
the journey of the sprout mm-hmm so you
can actually take things if you're you
know sprouting specifically right if
someone really wants so far feigned they
could have sprouts um they could have
the broccoli seeds they could consume
them on day 1 day 2 day 3 day 4 day 5
all the way to day 7 the you know from
my
perspective I'm eating them for a
combination of food and for
micronutrients and for the antioxidants
and I want to make sure that if I'm
having at least four ounces I usually
have 8 ounces of broccoli sprouts a day
I'm getting like my ample dose of so far
fame but I'm also getting the vitamin C
in the fibre but there's a whole kind of
opportunity to dig into the details
because there was research that
watercress had the most detoxifying
impact on benzene for smokers hmm
so there's you know as the research is
unfolding probably every single one of
these seeds sprouts has a whole story a
whole journey a whole kind of slew of
benefits that will be revealed if you
had to pick one what's the best one I
know you hate this question but I mean I
think for food and sustenance it would
be the sunflower sprouts and just think
about this the sunflower that little
seed if you soak it and let it grow you
can have a 5 inch sunflower sprout if
you transplant that into the soil it can
grow into like a 6 foot tall sunflower
that is so tuned in that it turns with
the Sun from sunrise to sunset and at
the end of its journey the flower will
start to seed and will generate five
hundred more seeds so this plant like
nature knows what to do and that's those
seeds can feed other wildlife they could
grow they could propagate there's all
these things so sunflowers for food and
sustenance because I love the way they
taste from a health perspective the
might of the broccoli spouts like why
I'm sure there's you know scientists
like Rhonda Patrick and Jed Fahey and
those people that are studying the
work on the nrf2 pathways and the
longevity and the anti-cancer and the
autism part that they're going into the
specifics around so far fame that's a
whole kind of subsection I just know
enough like that broccoli sprouts are
probably the longevity sprout and this
is the sussan sprout and i'll add one
more when i'm very physically active and
i'm working on the farm and on the land
and I want hearty er things the lentil
spouts garbanzo beans mung beans those
are just truly delicious and light yeah
you had shared on Instagram recently it
was a it was a mix kind of like this one
in front of me here but it was like your
protein Mex so it's not just you could
put a some combination of all of these
seeds into a jar and then you have I
think you call it your protein mixer so
yeah so you know different seeds for
different purposes play around and the
sense that I get is like just have fun
and experiment like it's so cheap and
easy and fast relative to trying to
plant a garden or something that seems a
lot more daunting well the thing is you
can be your own like kitchen gardener
right you can experiment what's the
craziest thing you've tried to sprout
are you oh I i I've I've sprouted
avocado seeds uh-huh
you know avocado pits right so and I put
that in there that's like a thing from
the 70s right you should put up for the
toothpicks into the avocado pit and on
the top of like a mason jar yeah what I
do is I just wait until I know that
they're like activated because either
gonna die and rot and mold or they're
gonna birth and as soon as they're
activated then I dry them out and then I
grind them and I put that powder into
like whatever I'm eating at that time
uh-huh it doesn't taste particularly
well but like I know there's some good
stuff in there uh-huh
I have one thing that I really like over
here
crowd these are one of these those are
hemp seeds uh-huh why do these look
different from the hemp seeds that I get
at my fancy grocery store because those
the ones you get the groceries to our
halt or shoot yes shelled right yeah so
so those still have the shell on them
and those are just like incredible like
I will sprout those literally a dozen at
a time and so I'm sprouting those for
the purpose of just getting that that
that plant intelligence inside and so if
you sprout them a little bit and you
soak them they just make it easier to do
buckwheat is another very very
satisfying part because it has a great
flavor it's chewy and it's easy to to
work with flax seeds to flax are
incredible to sprout like if you deflect
in like three or four days what you
normally see the little brown or golden
flax seed will have a tail that's five
times its size mmm and it's just alive
and when you sprout you remove the
enzyme inhibitors and the phytic acid
breaks down so you're even getting a
more digestible seed when when you're
sprouting it and soaking it in
germinating it when I think about trying
to meet my omega threes I think about
hemp seeds chia seeds and flax seeds so
if I'm sprouting those is there an
increase in the omega-3s or a more
bioavailable like what is the difference
I think that you get the bioavailability
I think there's a filer to the sulfur
fain I think there's a finite amount of
the Omega threes that's in every one of
those seeds mm-hmm and the benefit of
sprouting them is that you know I'm sure
you've had like you know kale where the
stem is so you know so hard and so rough
that you just want to separate the leaf
from the stem the sprouts are just so
tender
that there's just a very fine line
between the soluble and insoluble fiber
that acts is that prebiotic and just
easy to easy to absorb so I think the
younger tender vegetables are just ready
to eat and easy to absorb hmm on the
subject of of trying to redress the
problems incident to food deserts and
accessibility to healthy foods we've
seen quite a bit of progress in terms of
urban gardening you know there's guys
like Ron Finley out there who are yeah
like they're transforming these you know
downtrodden
neighborhoods and revitalizing them by
teaching people how to grow their own
food and that's cool that's happening
everywhere rooftop gardens and the like
amazing but those are our sort of land
intensive by comparison to what you're
talking about has there been any kind of
pilot programs or anybody who's leading
the charge in terms of education and
adoption when it comes to you know these
areas of you know urban blight so to
speak I mean on my agenda is to inspire
sprouting clubs and to be able to have
the connectivity that if someone like
for example you may love Chia and you
may be sprouting the Chia and Blake
could be the guy who loves sunflowers
and if you think on a community level if
you up your game and instead of using
half pint or pint or half gallon you use
a food grade 5 gallon bucket you could
be making copious amounts of sprouts and
if you have 4 or 5 people in these
little sprouting clubs people can come
together and share their wares and go
back to an early bounty stage so that
you're not having to you know run your
whole kitchen into a spout form you
could focus on one level of expertise
and I think that I was working with I
don't know if you saw the video that
Izabella Miko oh is that the one where
she's doing the zoom call with her
boyfriend
yeah yeah so before that the videos like
a comedian actress right
yeah very successful comedian actress
and by the way that video was band
shadow band on Instagram oh it was so
funny
I liked it it's funny but it was a
little racy but the video we were going
to do before the last frame the very end
of the video like put it a little bit
over the top but up until that point
it's fun it's funny she's she's funny
but the video we were going to do which
was much more serious was she volunteers
in a Food Kitchen and she was going to
go into the food kitchen and invite me
in and we were gonna teach them how to
grow their own sprouts in the food
kitchen uh-huh so the the people that
were farthest shot of having organic
vegetables might have the most
nutritionally packed high volume high
nutrition on a regular basis because at
the end of the day it's a food as
expensive and you know we didn't talk
about this I don't know if we're going
to talk about it
but I I can't not mentioned that sprouts
are the most local food you could have
right you take the seeds and you can
grow them on your own kitchen countertop
they also require the least amount of
water I mean if you just think about how
many gallons of water it takes to
prepare one pound of beef what's your
latest research that or data point on
that on what one cific lee one pound of
beef or one hamburger the stats are off
the top of my head but you know it's
thousands yeah
thousands so this is from the
environmental perspective it's local its
organic there's little waste and it's
the least amount of resources
it's the anti juicer oh yeah it's it
just is
it just is which I do want to ask you
about I want to not right now I want to
I want to continue this conversation but
I think that the the challenge is going
to be with education and adoption in the
sense that people can wrap their heads
around like okay I'm growing tomatoes I
know what that tastes like or you know
fruits and vegetables and things like
that but you're asking a community of
people that you know is is operating on
a very low budget and probably eating a
lot of fast food and whatever bags of
chips that they can get at the corner
bodega to start you know eating
something that is not only relatively
foreign and considered to be a garnish
and something you would tolerate but not
actually look forward to and and now
eating that like is basically like
snacks and is a larger portion of a meal
like that's a tough sell I mean I have
you know I put my foot I put my phone
down I could show you a video of this
obese woman who was a cleaner you know
in in on for one of the houses out at
wonder Valley and she'd always be hungry
and you know just didn't plan to bring
food to work right so she'd always be
hungry and my refrigerator
you know either had fruit in it that
cost me a bloody fortune at the farmers
market once a week or sprouts so I would
always just hand her sprouts so I'd say
put your hands out and I'd pour in you
know 1 cup 2 cup of sprouts and now she
has four kids single mother I gave her
two sprouting jars some seeds start her
off and now she's sprouting and I'll
show you the little video after she's
like eating the sprouts with no
flavoring no nothing and like she's a
her body is adopted and she's craving
these healthy food
that's pretty cool so you take her
you take Zhu G mu foo mmm you take chef
jean-georges you take these other like
guys who you know dr. B who you just you
know interviewed you know who's a
medical doctor and promoting it that
this sprout consciousness these seeds
are being planted mm-hmm and this is
something that and we'd you this in our
Instagram life like this is something
that is like we've all been sitting on
and this is not a magic pill like
everyone wants the magic pill you know
they want the vaccine they want someone
to solve their problem for them and if
someone were to sit and you know most
people just because they're you know and
this is all about the Equality like
being where I came from
and I spent time in the military you
know where I was an outcast in the
military and like I seem to be an
outcast in most places where I go but
not in my house do I feel very at home
in your house but in in the idea that if
you take the time to message to these
people and to talk to them it's rational
and if it's rational if it's accessible
like I'm not like there are things that
taste bad that you develop the habit for
and I know you've openly spoken about
alcohol mm-hmm right did you like the
taste of liquor the first time you had
it not initially grows on you pretty
quick oh okay
I think sprouts will authentically grow
on you pretty quickly and grow in you
grow on you and in either house yeah and
and take over and and by the way this
green is very good for the house air
quality in the house indoor air quality
huh where do you get the seeds like if
somebody's wrapping their heads around
like how to begin they're like all right
well I got to get the seeds Oh
start ice and jar seeds I mean you can
buy these I'm sure there's all kinds of
fancy kits and racks and things that you
can find online but just the basics the
debate the basic the very basics any
mason jar with cheesecloth I prefer
organic cheesecloth
is that is the main sprouting equipment
you don't need a fancy rack I use for
the amount of jars that I have juggling
I use a bamboo dish drying tray that I
spent $20 on and I can hold you know ten
jars on there and it's at the perfect
angle for for emptying those and then on
the seeds what I look for when I buy
seeds are organic seeds designed
specifically for sprouting that have
been tested for pathogens and that have
a high germination rate and those are
like my four criteria but now companies
like sprout man dot-com all their seeds
meet every one of those criteria huh
true leaf market which started selling
wheatgrass kits twenty years ago and now
evolved where you can buy seeds by the
truckload they're brand handy pantry is
organic seeds designed for sprouting so
you don't want to just go to the grocery
store and buy some dried black beans and
try it that way like there's there's a
specific type of yeah see that like when
you say like made for sprouting like
what does that mean what how does that
differentiate from what you would find
at the grocery it's a great question the
the sprouting seeds are the freshest
seeds that have been handled with the
most care mmm and this like the black
beans that might be in the bulk bin in
the health food store may have been who
knows how old and where they came from
and they will have the lowest
germination rate and the problem with
low germination rate when you're
spouting is that they can yield to mold
and they're just not going to be good if
you're cooking them it just doesn't
matter right right and if
you're planting them in the ground it
doesn't matter so that's where you know
it's important but the the difference
between today and when I start to write
the book I'm 2 years ago it's like the
market is just growing no pondan no pun
intended it's just growing and it's
becoming easier and now I'm even seeing
in health food stores packs of organic
sprouting seeds and sections one thing
that you do have to be somewhat mindful
of is making sure that you don't let
them go Rance it right like there they
can become toxic if they sit around for
too long I I would say that someone
asked that in a comment - Juji mu foo
uh-huh and said oh I hear that sprouts
can have both think that and there it
scares them off from doing this because
they don't want to suddenly make
themselves sick yeah
and I think that most instances and
there's probably the the number one
cause of foodborne illness in the
country is chicken and they actually
ship chicken the legal length limits of
Salmonella on chicken is they're
actually allowed to ship chicken with
Salmonella on it because they can't not
it's just too hard to deal with it so if
you think about foodborne illness from
chicken dairy fish versus vegetables
there's almost no comparison and the
amount of instances of a foodborne
illness from sprouting at home like I've
never heard of it and I think that if
you're doing it on your own like if they
go bad you will smell it and taste it
and you'll have a natural reaction to
but uh so I I think that the it's
important to pay attention to your
sprouting but I don't I'm not the least
bit you know worried there are people
that may have
concerns about specific sprouts and
other levels and if they have issues you
know you can explore that with and
what's your what's your feeling on the
lectins and don't get me started okay
you know like that's a whole other you
know rabbit hole that we could go down
on there's a lot of fear around lectins
there's a certain particular doctor
who's made a lot of statements around
that that have scared people off from
eating foods that are that are you know
healthy and should be part of
everybody's diet like beans which is the
staple of every Blue Zones you know
place like that but I would I know that
you talked about lectins in in in the
book specifically and there are people
that worry about that kind of thing you
know there's a lot of YouTube videos and
sort of information swirling around on
the internet so why don't you put
matters to rights on your perspective
yeah my perspective is that when you
sprout legumes and you say legumes or
goom's how do you know I say legumes
legumes probably like a mess yeah a
proper do we want to be do I don't want
to be proper so if you're sprouting
legumes some people if they have an
issue with legumes you know don't eat
them but you'll know but I I think that
sprouts are the easiest
you know like evidence of of this
becoming mainstream
Cady wells of wellness mama huge sprout
fan mmm-hmm and literally we we did an
interview and I did her podcast you know
where she's recommending sprouts to
young mothers that are birthing which
are probably the most susceptible you
know people to you know dietary parts
because they're breastfeeding and
they're taking care of things and people
ask her are you concerned you know with
this and no mmm
so I think the fear of of one you know
one case being blown out of proportion
too
kind of throw out all this good stuff to
keep people in kind of in the system
have you been to Burning Man never have
so I only learned this after being a
burner for a while what it meant about
Burning Man it's like the anti system
like you know it's against the system
and I talked about like my plan for this
burned which isn't happening this year
was to bring in sprouting seeds and do a
sprout camp where you would just like
that would be the gift turning all these
people on to sprouts and it would be the
greatest Leave No Trace item because you
know people bring in truckloads of food
and packaging and things and garbage and
they have to take them out so the only
service that Burning Man provided was
porta-potties uh-huh so you bring you
bring in your seeds you spout them and
you actually will leave no trace and be
able to leave without packaging so
there's so many things about spouts on
the nutrition side on the packaging side
on the environmental resource side and
on the brain like you know what when I
think about my brain today I'm gonna be
54 years old in two weeks I've never
been sharper clearer more energy more
discipline because there's no processed
food like I'm meeting the things that I
think that my body is just jiving with
yeah well you look great I said that at
the minute that you walked in the door
and I probably saw you like I don't know
six weeks ago or something like that
like and I know that you've been running
a lot and you've been wearing the Vibram
FiveFingers running out in the desert
and you have a nice color to yourself
and there's a brightness in your eye
like you are you know certainly if
nothing else like a living embodiment of
you know healthy lifestyle like your
energy is infectious you have so much
enthusiasm for this lifestyle and the
things that you talk about you talk
about it so eloquently and beautifully
and you are the ambassador
that we need like how are we gonna clone
Doug Evans so he can go into all of
these communities espouse the you know
revolutionary benefits of you know
eating this way I mean you have to plant
a lot of seeds rich the seed the seed
metaphor just keeps circling back here
and look I think I think it makes sense
and you know if you see like you know
I've been on Instagram for for awhile
and I didn't engage I didn't do things
but now like um people ask questions I'm
responding to the questions the most
amazing thing is like I'm learning by
having to think through these corner
case examples and it's expanding like my
my sphere from the community of the
collective intelligence uh-huh and the
fact that now all these diverse range of
people are now like sprouting and it
resonates with them that's that's it so
I think how do we do it it's like one
person at a time
like I'll engage in a conversation with
one person online or physically or the
farmers market in the Joshua tree
farmers market there's a little you know
couple that sells microgreens uh-huh
and they're now selling microgreens and
they're selling my book hmm and I'm
giving them every week I'm giving them
ideas of what to do to bake it make it
easier for them to share the
consciousness and people are like buying
the book that I never like it's so
strange because it was hard for me to
write a sentence like having barely
gotten through high school writing a
book like I you know for virtually no
money like writing the book and having
that part was something that was
missionary and it's got to be incredibly
gratifying when you see people that you
wouldn't suspect would be interested in
what you have to say like cotton hang on
to it
on lines very cool I mean the the idea
and you know I had spoken to you that I
I went I met Marianne Williamson right
and you know I listened to return to
love I had read A Course in Miracles and
you know her ideals and she had talked
about reparations you know and as part
of her policy like in one part I didn't
feel like like the spouts conversation
would pique her interest but the other
part said I I think this is so important
that you know can i infect her
consciousness you know with lighting
this up for spouts like is this
important enough you know for her to
take seriously and now I'm seeing like
this you know and I'm saying this
knowing where we are today in the world
and what's going on this is one of the
most important conversations that people
can have is about diet and lifestyle
nutrition and I don't know how many of
the people on your guests on your
podcast have talked about that decision
of what you put in your mouth and how it
affects your life and if this could be
something for literally pennies a
serving dollars a day to be able to up
the nutrition and level the game and if
people can have better memory better
energy better fit because there's all
this unconscious bias there's all of
this kind of prejudice and limitations
and you know I have a tribal ISM
tribalism and this is unifying like
people you know around food and
collectivity but you know what is the
level of unconscious bias around people
that are overweight and obese and it's
just another form of discrimination so
this is I think plants bring people I
could tell you the the woman who I
started I village I forgot her name
and she has been a long-term vegetarian
and then when she took the company
public she started to eat meat and she
said I need to eat meat in order to to
fend off the toxicity of the public
environment and all these other people
then she resigned and then she went back
to being a vegetarian like the the idea
of the toxicity you know of of the
aggression that I find I'm a much nicer
Pro so I was trying to understand what
you were saying basically you're saying
like in order
she felt like in order for her to kind
of compete in this you know clawing
world of masculine you know corporate
executives that she had to eat meat to
like she eat maybe at that level of
consciousness yeah like you know she
went like she reverted back to more
primal you know survival and do it I
didn't fully get that but it was
something that you know I just became
aware of and then afterwards she went
back to eating plants hmm so I I think
that you know to answer go back to the
bigger question you asked how does this
happen it's one person at a time
it's literally having conversations and
building a collective consciousness like
at some point though there's you know
Cal came on to the scene right and Cal
is no more healthy than collard greens
or chard hmm right it does have yeah but
it became the thing it's so interesting
that that was the one that got selected
yeah and Brussels sprouts
became a thing right did you see the
Brussels sprout not like kale though
yeah I know I know I
who are these publicists behind pulling
the levers behind there was gonna be the
thing there was an artificial
organization called that I talk about in
the book well like a woman kind of
created the National kale Growers
Association and launched PR and did all
this stuff
Kael as a passion project but it wasn't
it was like her project and it ignited
and I think that you know sprouts have
been around for a really long time my
pitch I pitched one publisher in New
York and I made the recipes and I
brought her some seeds and there never
been a book on sprouting from a major
publisher I mean this is like mmm so all
these things were and now I think this
is the time for sprouting has come he
said it here first my friends well
listen look you know undoubtedly were
were you know in the midst of an insane
health crisis right now obesity rates
cancer diabetes heart disease all of
these things are escalating rapidly
childhood obesity etc and it's creating
all these downstream health impacts as
well and we're all well aware of the
fact that the people who are most at
risk for having severe cases of
coronavirus are the people with you know
sort of these cofactor health problems
comorbidity issues and so now is the
time people if there was ever a time now
and it's not about what I like about
this also is that it's it's not about
what you're removing from your diet it's
about building something in that we can
all unite around that doesn't have
anything to do with tribalism or
whatever kind of like worldview or
particular you know diet proclivity that
you happen to adhere to yeah I mean I'm
done with having conversations about
telling people what they shouldn't eat
anymore
it's just I just don't have one more
breath of energy to do that like I'm
done but I will tell them to eat sprouts
and you have I can we step it back a
little bit you're so we've known each
other for many years I think we met
around 2011 or 2012 something yeah john
joseph filippi cafe was it achieve a
mukti or did we meet at the seed i
believe the seed thing right like oh
yeah we met that seed
it's in New York maybe but I remember
walking and you were going to meet with
John Joseph and then we went to there
and had dinner
so thanks oh yeah I think you're right I
think you're right in any event we've
known each other for many years
interestingly like we have friends
circles that intersect that I continue
to learn that you new people that I know
like you just posted about Jesse its ler
I didn't realize that you went way back
with Jesse yeah oh yeah he's Oh G right
we we've been friends for a long time
and I've watched you you know through a
portion of your organic Avenue days and
and was certainly you know there
throughout the whole juice arrow
adventure the first time that you came
on the podcast I actually for people
that are newer to the show like I went
to the juice arrow headquarters in San
Francisco well first of all it's you
invited me out to the facility in Los
Angeles this gigantic place that you
were just building out and then I went
and visited you in San Francisco I was
in the juice arrow offices the evening
just prior to you announcing publicly
what you were doing and there was gonna
be this New York Times article coming
out and you had board members there and
there was a lot of excitement and
activity and we carved out an hour and a
half in your office to bang out a
podcast and then juice era was birthed
into the world and you went on this
crazy rollercoaster ride of an adventure
with some pretty high highs and some
pretty low lows and I've talked about
this with other people on the podcast
sense but you know I love you Doug and I
always you know I believed in you and I
still believe in you and I think that
there's been a lot of misunderstanding
about what went down and I wanted to
provide you with the opportunity to talk
a little bit about that experience
because when people think juice arrow
you know there's a certain Association
that comes with that but that's not like
most things that's not really the full
story yeah so one of the things that we
live in a society where everyone is
focused on money and so for me
when I came up with the vision for juice
era which was
hardware/software sustainable packaging
fresh supply chain farm-fresh produce
nutrition protocol and having an
integrated solution I did that because I
wanted people to have accessibility to
more servings of fruits and vegetables
so US Dietary Guidelines said 7 to 13
servings of fruits and vegetables a day
the average American was consuming less
than one and I knew that people who
bought a home juicer where you were
using it once or twice a month but
people who were using an espresso
machine we're using it once or twice a
day and so having spent 10 years of my
life making juice I knew a lot about how
to make juice and I used a dozens of
different juicers so I put my kind of
head around could I make a juicer that
was fresh juice which everything that
was in a bottle wasn't fresh and I
didn't believe the HPP and the
pasteurization part hot pasteurization
cold fast pasteurization wasn't fresh
and being like Who I am energetically I
wouldn't drink those juices so I wanted
my design criteria was how do you have a
fresh juice on demand in two minutes so
I built a prototype with a welder that
was doing kitchen equipment on the
corner on the corner of Bowery and Canal
in Chinatown okay where they I could
barely communicate with them and they
built me a first prototype or one of the
first prototypes which was literally a
hot-water bottle that we were inflating
with an airbrush compressor to push two
cutting boards together to create the
force because you needed a lot of
force to extract juice and if you were
to go to any cold-pressed juice shop in
the United States maybe around the world
I haven't been around the world to see
them the way you make cold-pressed juice
was you take produce you dice it slice
it chop it shred it to create like a
slurry you know where there's chunks of
in it but you have to open up the
cellular walls and if you watch the
medical medium telling you how do you
make celery juice without a juicer he
tells you to blend it and then put in
cheesecloth and wring it out to make
your juice so that's just how juice was
made the insight was if you took the
produce you put it in the bag and then
you put it in another bag then you put
it in the machine you could press
without making a mess and so to do all
that was it was a big deal so I made
prototype after prototype and then we
realized that this was much harder to do
then we thought then than we thought
like there were so many pinch points
that someone could get hurt on in the
machine like if you know you have all
this force so we had to design the
machine so there's no pain points and
the original machines was like the size
of a television like it was just big and
that wasn't a consumer product so we
just had to design it smaller and
smaller so fast-forward the the reason
why people funded the business because
it really was the the freshest most
delicious juice that you could have it
really took two minutes and it really
worked but in order to make that magic
you needed to have a fresh produce
supply chain you needed to make the
packaging you needed to do the
distribution you needed like I didn't
want a Wi-Fi connected machine that
wasn't my vision I didn't come from I'm
not a millennial I didn't want that but
in
1997 when Eduardo from drinking raw
juice I didn't want to risk anyone ever
getting sick from having a raw product
so the the overhead that we would have
to put around protecting someone from
consuming because we live I don't know
like one last time you had milk in your
house it for me it's been years but no
one believes expiration dates so people
would go they do the sniff test and then
if it would sour they'd throw it out and
if it wasn't but how can you determine
if produce was fresh when it was in a
sealed packaging that was opaque because
the produce was sensitive to light and
you put it in the refrigerator there's
no difference between the fresh pack and
the old the Wi-Fi enabled aspect of it
you know setting aside the bells and
whistles of the like wired household or
whatever was simply to be a check on on
the the produce to make sure that it was
fresh right it was a it was a way of
like sort of block chaining the supply
chain to make sure that you know and if
it and if it wasn't fresher the thing
wouldn't press wouldn't pray but the
thing is here's the thing so the
narrative that got spun is here's a guy
he comes to Silicon Valley
he raids he raises an ungodly amount of
money from some very important people
that he apparently hoodwinked into this
vision of creating a juice machine which
is seven hundred dollars and then you
got to subscribe and get these packs and
they're like I don't know what are they
five seven dollars a piece yeah this is
like the ultimate in Silicon Valley
being checked out from you know what
where America is truly at and what
people really need and and and it became
this symbol of excess and so much so
that people were cheering for its demise
and it became this like meme right like
where the schadenfreude was you know
essentially unparalleled and all of that
got directed at you yeah being being the
brainchild of all of us and it began I I
would say we've had many conversations
about
this but I would say that it began with
the publication of that New York Times
article that came out the morning after
we had our first podcast that spun you
in a certain light and you and the team
of juice arrow were never able to gain
control of the narrative and that and
that narrative that began with the New
York Times story just spiraled out of
control and began to build and build and
build and tell me until it just became
impossible for you to even tell your
version of the story yeah I think the
you know many mistakes you know and I
told Greg one of the mistakes but one of
the major mistakes was ever ever telling
anyone how much money we raised for the
business because if we you know people
there are five thousand dollar coffee
makers or fifteen thousand dollar coffee
makers there are Prada bags like people
fly first place first class chartered
air private air people by you know you
can buy a Hyundai or you could buy a
Rolls Royce so people choose to use
their money and when Starbucks opened up
their new juice plant for evolution
fresh they spent a hundred million
dollars they couldn't even get a press
release out no one cared so it was just
the the fact that people knew how much
money we raised which is a lot of money
but we were doing a lot of things that
R&D in the tech was pretty heavy but a
lot of that went into the supply chain
like how are you going to like what are
the deals that you're making with all of
these farms like where's all this food
coming from how is it being shipped like
the logistics of all of that are a huge
part of the longer-term business that
you were mapping out that I don't think
people truly understood and the second
thing is the machine that cost $700 was
the first iteration like you had already
huge showed me designs for the newer
version which was meant to come out you
know basically shortly after the company
got shuttered that was like half the
price that pressed like I don't know
like 30 or 40 percent more juice
much cheaper price point like there's an
economy of scale here that had this
thing been given the runway to play
itself out you would have arrived at a
place where the press would have been
you know price effective and all of
these things would have made much more
sense but you couldn't get to that point
yeah I mean there's so many mistakes I
made so many mistakes and I think I own
all the mistakes like you know I loved
the plant that we had in LA
there's a hundred eleven thousand square
feet on four and a half acres and we had
a choice we could have been a 10,000
square foot plant a 20,000 and this
plant was a food processing facility
that was already built and it had it was
all refrigerated and it had floor drains
and it had FDA certification and it was
LEED Gold certified and it had solar and
so the Silicon Valley mindset is you
have to be thinking about scale and so
when you moved into that operation then
that was capable of producing a million
packs a week and we were producing
50,000 packs a week and so had we had a
facility to do the 50,000 packs um a
week it would have been ten thousand ten
thousand square feet and so um my
limited mind said couldn't imagine not
the thing not growing at the the pace
was going to grow I didn't want I knew
from my experience before how difficult
it is to move plants like it's just
really difficult to set up all the
systems and the food safety and to move
plants but in hindsight if we would have
been in a smaller plant without the
robotic automation and the larger scale
things and we would have had guys and
type men or women in Tyvek suits with
ice cream scoopers filling the packs
with with heat sealing um would have
been the better thing to do for verse
one and so I didn't have the ability to
do the calculus that said okay we're
only going to do a thousand versions of
the first one it's only going to be here
and no one will know what it costs
there'll be no press release there'll be
no things we'll just work it and then
that would have given us time to do
version two so people don't know this
today on your project like uber is
losing 11 million dollars a day right 11
million a day but they have 4 billion or
so on the balance sheet so they're able
to do that so the Silicon Valley part is
you have to think big you enter that
that spectrum you have to think big and
if you make a mistake it's unforgiving
and so the media of like bloomberg
writing an article that you could
squeeze the pack by hand well that was
the nail in the coffin when people were
squeezing it and then people were making
YouTube videos about that so you know
what's what happened there I mean
because technically you could squeeze if
you squeezed it hard enough you could
squeeze it out well hard enough and long
enough with a technique you know to do
it and I'm happy to show you a video of
like a football player squeezing it a
model squeezing it it was a rigorous
two-minute part but that would be like
saying you could take an espresso pod
pour hot water over it and get coffee
and you don't need the Nespresso machine
so the idea of that you could squeeze
the pack by hand is like that's just how
juice was made and but the experience
was you know in your household where you
had you know multiple people juicing you
know using the machine was easy you
press the button and it does the work
and if you had to squeeze the pack by
hand and do it for the two minutes or so
then people wouldn't use it and that the
best example like that that we had was
after the Bloomberg our
came out the company said hey if you
want a refund if you're unhappy if you
feel like you were duped send back a
machine no matter what you paid for it
when you bought it he'll give you a
hundred percent refund and less than
five percent of the people sent back
their machines 95% of the people
continued to use their juice arrow nine
nine point two times a week so all
metrics I mean this is a crazy thing for
me to look at but all metrics other than
the fact that the business is out of
business and it's gone and it's sad we
sold thousands of machines we sold over
a million packs and people buy the
machine loved it but everyone else hated
it yeah people that that didn't try it
or use it just simply made fun of it
because it was the easy thing to do and
I can tell you when we had it like I was
drinking tons of green juice all the
time and I don't like I make smoothies
now but I'm not getting out our clunky
juicer and making juice yeah I just
don't don't do it and that was really
the motivation behind this as mr. juice
guy yourself who you know created
organic Avenue co-created it you know
better than anybody that it's a
cumbersome process and the whole idea
here was to make this seamless and easy
for people so that they would be
ingesting more healthy foods yeah and
you know from my perspective as an
entrepreneur right many aspects of the
business failed just failed I mean
that's you know the the fact from others
we did great like the product worked you
know it really worked it did what was
supposed to do the messaging and the
communications was like terrible you
guys never control the story that was my
whole thing I was you never were able to
get out in front and dictate the message
that you wanted people to hear about
what you were doing you were always
reacting to some news article or
something else something that somebody
else was saying well and it was
unpressed
like the amount of vitriol it was
intense it was like like you know I
can't imagine you know what it must have
felt like for you to be on the receiving
end of such a tirade of you know
hypercritical well news I mean it's
almost like you know up until eight days
ago the entire conversation was about
kovat right and now the entire like no
one's even talking about covin but
people are I was at the protest less
than half the people had masks on
yesterday so conversations shift when
the article came out the Bloomberg
article the company and I was no longer
CEO which was another mistake that I
made I never should have turned my baby
over but it's my mistake no one put a
gun to my head not at that point so but
when the article came out the top crisis
management PR firms that money could buy
said it'll pass and this was the top
advice and the then CEO you know was
responding with the fact that oh okay
just lay low and they'll go pick on
someone else the next day but the the
perfect storm just led into an avalanche
and then even though the company I mean
this is crazy the company was still
growing the products were still selling
like no this wasn't like Thoreau knows
where they were doing false finger
pricks with fake tests like the the the
product did was supposed to do the fact
that there are alternative ways I could
wash this shirt in my kitchen sink with
less soap less water and faster than
using my Whirlpool washing machine but
no one's protesting whirlpool that's a
good point right that other than other
than
not making public the amount of money
that was raised and it's already public
it doesn't matter no I know now I'm
saying I'm saying if you could have done
it again like what are the things that
you would that you've learned that you
would do differently other than like the
press release about the the venture
raise or or stepping down as CEO like as
you know as a serial entrepreneur a seed
entrepreneur yeah I'm gonna call you now
looking back on this adventure that
you've been on I mean I'm sure there
it's it's littered with lessons for
people that are watching or listening
who are on their own entrepreneurial
journey about you know what the
landmines are what to look out for what
to avoid what to you know focus on a few
people have you know raise that amount
of money sort of been celebrated by
Silicon Valley and then you know
basically vilified like the the highs of
the high highs in the low lows I think
are instructive I I mean the it's so
many so I think for one like I was
operating like my hair was on fire
you're a maniac like I remember visiting
you in San Francisco and it was like I I
don't think you were sleeping or like
evey if you had an apartment you never
went to it like you were just literally
on fire 24 hours a day yeah and that
being on fire did not get the best
results from the team like you know
Silicon Valley operates in in these
Sprint's and people are working but when
you're working that fast that you don't
get a chance for the organization to
really learn and take over and you don't
solve the problems you know in
necessarily the most cost-efficient way
and you're making rash decisions because
there's some target date because the
money will run out and you need to do
your next round and you need to hit this
part that the the structure is really
designed for you know grand slam home
run you know or wipeout so you know if I
were doing it again today like I would
gone a lot slower and would have
redefined different parts and say oh
well okay in the first year we'll do a
thousand machines they're only gonna go
local we don't need anybody in PR and
marketing I mean I think we had like a
six person marketing team right and you
know we we were a local product it was
only available in California but we had
national press right so you're like we
weren't doing national marketing but if
we would have just gone slower right
still working with a good intent space I
think we would have made different
decisions and you know not having a big
plant like like why would a start-up
need to recruit the president of
Campbell Soup to come from a billion
dollar operation to a company doing a
hundred thousand dollars in revenue like
why why why do that so just the focus
you take you know to do things like that
were were were you know huge the the
thing about going B to B versus B to see
our product did both and in hindsight it
was expensive for a consumer and too
inexpensive for a business hmm so had we
focused on a more robust machine just
for businesses all of the the and and
that's where we were towards the end
when we were in Whole Foods and we were
in lop encoded en and we're in the John
George restaurants and all the parts
where people were able to get this
exquisite product I mean we were in the
top restaurants you know in New York in
LA and you could buy it by the glass
yeah it seems in retrospect that a smart
move would have been to create a premium
version of the machine
that looked beautiful like a beautiful
espresso machine that that would you
know allow the customer when they were
visiting that restaurant or that retail
outlet or what
to buy their very fine juice and people
would look forward to that and it would
be considered like this luxury item and
you could perfect your systems over time
and slowly and organically create that
consumer demand so by the time you had a
consumer friendly cost you know
affordable machine there would be a huge
amount of people ready and willing and
excited to buy something like that yeah
I mean you know only two years after you
know we we started the journey towards a
consumer did I interview a former
founder executive board member of Keurig
and the original Keurig machine was
$1500 hmm and today it's $99 so so I
think that the that's another you know
just a strategic play but I'll also tell
you that a b2b like juice machine
back-end that would be in supermarkets
non consumer product not fundable in
Silicon Valley right right yeah it's a
different thing you're not like this
fancy sexy technology company yet no
ompletely different yeah no one knows
the name of the oven that Starbucks uses
to reheat the grilled cheese you know
that they're selling there no one knows
that well what did you learn about the
Silicon Valley culture or the venture
capital you know world like that's
shrouded in in kind of its own sexy
version of mystery
everybody's aspiring to be able to go
pitch their startup to you know
andreessen horowitz or you know kleiner
perkins and these companies that you're
familiar with so paint the picture of
the reality of what it's like to be a
company funded by one of those oddities
it you know it's really interesting I
think those venture capitalists go into
the game knowing that 75% of those
companies will not make it right and
won't make it like a publisher doling
out advances on books yes the Harry
Potter that you know finances everybody
else's book so so I think there's you
know a lot of people like did you see
the general magic movie hmm no I don't
think so what is that it's it's a
documentary it's on Netflix or somewhere
and soon but it's about you know Tony
Fadell and Mark parot the next yeah that
nest nest nest and then Google but it's
about Joni I met in your office right
yeah yeah um maybe maybe he was on your
board right no Matt Rogers was on Oh
Matt is who I met then yeah so um but
Tony's Tony's great entrepreneur but
Tony was like a kid wet-behind-the-ears
and he worked at this spin-off of Apple
called general magic where John Sculley
spun off this group to make a handheld
which was basically the iPhone 20 years
ago it had email it had a phone it had
things it was big and bulky and the best
people in the world like the people who
developed the Macintosh were assigned to
this thing and then Scully ended up
screwing them launching the nude end
before they could launch the general
magic and they lost a boatload of money
and they all went away and Tony Fadell
ended up going to Apple and working on
the iPhone and then starting Nast and
Andy Rubin ended up going to Google and
creating Android and all the everyone
like just dissipated 20 years later
everyone was successful except the CEO
he never surfaced again but it's just a
story so so this the tales of Silicon
Valley are that you must swing for the
fences like no one is interested in
number two or number three you know like
lyft you know is did okay but people
were interested in uber right so the
breakaways and how you can dominate and
in
raising the capital is an accomplishment
but really like I love you know Sara
Blakely its banks you know where you
know she saved $5,000 hustled and and
Bill built a business selling product
and wheeling and dealing yeah there is a
weird backwards nature to this in the
sense that we celebrate these people who
who who are successful with raising
tremendous amounts of tremendous amounts
of money but essentially all they're
doing is like giving away large portions
of their company yeah we should be
celebrating the people who are able to
find a way to not have to do that and
also to celebrate people that just
create a successful business we're in
this weird moment where unless it's a
unicorn it's not successful what's wrong
with building a business that just does
well every year even if it's not growing
at some crazy rate well I think that you
know part of it is the the society we
live in you know which is why the
country is bifurcated and there's all
these things going on it's what people
are focusing on and so the you know what
I took from you know juice arrow was
that it was a good I was it I think was
a big idea and I think it worked but I
think that there are ways to approach
things differently and it's hard to see
your blind spots so if if we would have
known like we did market research and
market research said the total
addressable market for a $700 juicer was
three million people in the state of
California and what really came out was
maybe we had the addressable market for
$700 juicer was 30,000 people and you
know you do all this research and it's
wrong and so I think raising money is
innovation and people are funding create
innovation so if you want if you have a
big idea and you need a lot of money
like you couldn't build a computer per
se without at scale to go to
manufacturing without it right so you
need you need to do sir pens on what
kind of idea it is so I I think that
there are some people they are like in
all industries there are some people
there that are really nice really honest
some people are fair weathered some
people are duplicitous and you never you
never know who you're dealing with and -
but it's definitely about the money in
Silicon Valley mm-hmm like it's about
the money the interesting journey for
you or for me watching you kind of go
through this is is you know the kind of
emotional and spiritual evolution that
it catalyzed in you like I I saw
somebody who really had to who-who-who
kind of met his maker and was forced to
meet himself in a very profound way
because you know that external
validation got so stripped away from you
that you had to figure out a way to move
forward for yourself so tell me a little
bit about like what that was like I mean
at the end a lot of the attacks didn't
hurt because I knew like what my
intention was like my intention was I
want people to have more servings of
fruits and vegetables and and that's
what what I was doing and I made some
mistake
everybody that knows you knew that like
your friends all knew that yeah but in
the media like you know it's like the
the irony do you know what a Bloomberg
terminal is yeah right so on the
Bloomberg terminal 90% of the data you
can get on a Bloomberg terminal is
available on Google and Yahoo Finance
etc and they charge two thousand dollars
a month you know for it for this data
and so the the media
is about clickbait and about
sensationalism and I knew that what I
created had its flaws had its mistakes
etc but I thought it was a it was very
like I I appreciated the beauty and the
the thousands of problems that we solved
you know as a result of my three years
of being a maniac to launch on huh
so when someone would say oh you're this
or that I was like you have no idea what
you're talking about
and I'm not gonna waste my time
explaining it to you like it's just
there's no point so the hard part was
you know all of a sudden you're going to
all these conferences and you have all
these things and you're invited to party
went to every conference cuz you we
would talk on the phone or get tight
you'd read Google zeitgeist and you're a
Davos and you're a Ted and I mean you
there was I don't think there was a
conference that existed that you didn't
go to I I went to I went to a lot every
Tony Robbins I should add as well and
and what happened is then all of a
sudden you don't get invited anymore
right
right so but the point for me was that I
had to look at like what was my true
intention and I realized like I wanted
people to be healthier and you know I
never liked my most expensive car was a
Toyota Prius that I bought used right so
I never bought a house
you know at USERRA never bought the
expect never had no trappings and I ate
it and there weren't like restaurants
that really like I preferred eating my
own raw food like I would indulge in the
farmer's market so I didn't have any of
the trappings and that's what allowed me
to kind of move to the desert and really
like deepen my meditation practice
deepen my yoga practice you know gave me
time to really learn and reflect and you
know I gave you know originally and I
think you know this like right after
Dussehra I thought like oh my god I'm 50
years old no one's ever gonna hire me
again what am I going to do
and like I took this job you know for
this company we'll leave them nameless
and I spent two weeks there and like I
saw everything from the founders eyes
the CEOs eyes the venture eyes and I was
like there's lack of congruence here
like this like the integrity level here
is just not up to par I can sell this so
I literally broke my contract I left
money on the table
and and I and then I gave myself
permission for time to mourn you know
the loss and also time to reflect and
like I look at this now and saying where
I am with sprouts and the mission of
getting people to grow their own food
and food equality is so important and
that I'm grateful
like really grateful that I get to work
on this and I don't feel like I'm a
victim of some trap or some vitriol or
some silicon valley failure that was
just part of my journey that got me to
here mm-hmm
and I love my life now more than I ever
have
that's beautiful and you wouldn't change
it wouldn't change the path the
trajectory oh of course I mean I just
want to lie in the Sun and be massaged
gonna be fed it sounds like it sounds
like you kind of do that though hey look
we got to end this shortly but I I want
to I want to like you know paint the
picture of this compound that you've
built out in the middle of nowhere
I mean it's lit it is literally in the
main air it's not like directly in
joshua tree like it's out you know two
towns over Oh like truly in the middle
of nowhere on a flat desert piece of
land with 40 acres the the actual ranch
I live on is 25 acres ok but we have
other land nearby with hot springs all
right so there are these hot spring
and you've built these tubs and you're
kind of slowly creating dwellings on the
property friends can come and stay and
things like that
it's on Airbnb yeah there's there's a
bunch of houses on Airbnb uh-huh and so
anybody's listening this can come and
come book it and message me directly
know what is talked to me about you know
the day-to-day existence I mean it's
it's like a homesteading thing because
you really are you know about as far
you're not completely off the grid right
but like about as close as you can be
well we're off the water grill that
water grit but not electricity grow no I
mean what you know like I'm waiting for
the next like Silicon Valley
breakthrough on solar batteries yeah
because yeah I don't want to get stuck
with a 30-year lease you know on how
don't we keep having over how to do that
yeah the solution is to buy used panels
from some other solar farm that went out
and you'll still save half the money and
you'll we can work talk about that after
so so so the insight that I had and I
had a hunch I had never spent a night in
Joshua Tree I'd never been to Joshua
Tree National Park but I kept having
this vision that there were hot springs
there and so I got on a plane and I went
there and no hot springs isn't the
arthur springs that what is a - bunch
palms
that's down the hill that's Palm Springs
Desert Hot Springs but up the hill where
there's Joshua Tree and 29 palms no hot
springs and so I hired a geologist I
hired well drillers consultants Realtors
and I kept asking questions and then
it's seemingly like all of a sudden just
everything unfolded and then I bought
like a five acre piece of property with
a cabin on it that at 135 degree
geothermal hot spring right on the land
so the geologist was able to you you
literally went like prospecting
basically I just went there
people are looking for gold I was
looking for hot springs and between this
like group of people with we were able
to find it and then you know I'm just
putting this out there like land you
could still today buy five acres of land
in or around Joshua Tree for under five
thousand dollars maker it's crazy right
five acres beautiful view no light
pollution no noise pollution you're just
there and then you if you drill a well
you have a source of water and if you
have a hot spring well then you have an
oasis and so I just you know spent the
last two years instead of you know watch
and we have no TV no cable on the
property uh-huh so no TVs no radios no
cable we do have internet but I use that
time to really just learn like I like to
learn so I learned about sprouting and
we also have plant an organic farm and
I'm learning so we have a greenhouse and
we're doing straw bale raised beds
covered in Jude and planted melons and
tomatoes so and I've had to figure out
how do you disseminate water and we have
five streams of water we've got the hot
spring water then we have the hot spring
water that sits in an underground
cistern and becomes ambient then we have
a water chiller for the wim hof chilling
soaking tubs then we have the RO
desalination system so we could have
potable drinking water and then we have
the grey water that comes from the
soaking tubs that we use for irrigation
Wow
that's quite something and and it all
works and when you were a little kid
growing up in New York and going to
school in Harlem the Bronx or Brooklyn I
went to school I went to elementary
school in the Bronx I went to high
school in Harlem uh-huh
and ice imagined yourself living out in
the middle of the desert
I know when you were tagging subways and
running around I mean I came and
believed it now
I I wake up but I get the deepest sleeps
and it's just so beautiful there and I
think I'll be there for a while all
right well let's wrap it up final
thoughts on sprouting I think sprouting
is easy its accessible its inexpensive
its nutritious its plant-based and like
I want to it's like Oh Cole it's it's
local you know just you know when I when
I thought about sprouting I couldn't
believe it like I was questioning every
one of my hypothesis to see was it
flawed and this came out with like
shining colors and everything you know
what was it was good I I mean I can't
believe but I I'm pinching myself and
believe like sprouting is everything and
more like it's even more than then we've
even talked about like when you think
about the power of you know there's been
virtually no research whatsoever about
the power of consuming living plant
foods what that does to the mine to the
gut etc I mean this is just the
beginning but this is truly living
enzymatically rich fiber rich food mmm I
just I welcome people to try it and try
it they will I think I love you my
friend thank you for sharing your
message the book is the sprout book
basically everything you ever wanted to
know and more about sprouting and you've
got all these excerpts in their
interviews with doctors and then you've
got this whole you know all the all the
recipes and the how to you know
essentially everything you need to know
and while people are kind of locked in
their homes and unable to go out into
the world no better time to learn about
this begin practicing it yourselves and
to take better control of your health
and your
immunity and everything so thank you for
sharing that today you have been I just
want to acknowledge you like you just
you've been an amazing friend to not
just me but my wife my family and I love
you dearly you have a huge heart and I
just I want nothing but good things and
success for you so thanks for coming and
sharing with me today my pleasure I
think you know it I listened to your
podcast and it took every bit of my like
energy and positive thinking to feel
worthy to come onto this show like you
know that your second time I understand
but it's still I mean it's a real it's a
real honor and you know it's very
intimidating and but thank you thank you
for having me for the second time or
anytime my friend
all right well let's do it again all
right yep cool take us out with a piece
and plants peace peace
[Music]